in this tutorial we'll create an
authentication system
using react and go so this is
up it shows you are not logged in
and we can register our user so let me
register one user right now test
email will be tested test.com and the
password
is test when i register the user i will
redirect to the sign-in form
where here i can write the email that i
just created
and the password that i just created and
i can go to the main page where i show
hide test
so test is the name and i have a logout
button here where i can
log out so this is the authentication
that we will build also something to
mention
is that we will use http only cookies so
once we log in we'll generate this
cookie
that shows that we are logged in once we
remove it
we are logged out so if you want to see
how to make this page
follow this tutorial before building the
app
i would like to remind you that my
channel is a channel that combines
multiple frontend frameworks with
multiple backend frameworks
this tutorial covers react and go
but if you want to combine react with
one of these backend frameworks
or go with one of these fronted
frameworks
go to my channel and you will find the
videos there
i combined videos using playlist
now let's build the apps now let's
download and install go
before i start make sure to know the
basics
of go so if you are a total beginner
make sure to watch a tutorial about go
basics first
so with that being said let's get
started
click download go and download the right
version for your machine also make sure
to download mysql
download the mysql community server and
mysql workbench
also the golf framework that we will be
using is go fiber so
the fiber framework fiber is a framework
inspired by express.js so
if you know express.js it it will be
easier for you to learn
fiber so i'll copy this code
and in my project here which is an empty
folder
i'll create a go file main that go
i'll call a package main
and i'll create a function so paste the
code actually
so before i run this up first
make sure to get this package
so to get this package i already got it
from my machine but if you
don't have it you should run this
command go
get go fiber and this
will install it in your machine also
make sure to
configure your go path i will use
the version 1 here because the version 2
throws an error for some reason
and we will listen to port 8000 to run
this up
run go run main.go
and fiber will run on port 8000 let's go
to port 8000
localhost port 8000
hello world so this is our first
go up now let's connect with our
database
so i'll create a connection to my local
database here to mysql
so the user is root
password is root root and the database
is youtube
go out
so this is my local database which is
empty now let's connect with this
database
to connect with the database we will be
using
gorm so let's copy this uh
command here go get to install gorm
i'll close the server and install this
also make sure to install also the
driver i won't be using
sqlite but i will be using mysql
so the driver is mysql
so with this we can
connect with gorm so here i will import
so i can have multiple imports here if i
use the
brackets and here we need
gorm io slash gorm
and also gorm.io
driver mysql we need those two now let's
connect
with the database so we have a
connection
and then errors because go returns
can return multiple variables
gorm open
mysql open we need a string inside which
i will add it later
and the other parameter is
gorm config
so this is a connection
if an error happens so if error is
not nil we need
we need to panic so could
not connect to the database
so panic will stop our app if an error
happens
now the connection for the moment we
won't be using it so i will put an
underscore there
and uh if we don't panic here
it means that the connection is
successful so let's round up
so we panicked because i forgot to add
the
dns here so let's do that
so my user is root
then i need to pass a password which is
root
and then i put a net here and now
we need the database youtube
go out
so this is our local database connection
now let's run the app again and now we
can see that
fiber is running it means that we
successfully connected
with the database now let's restructure
the folders so create a folder here
database one folder
controllers
and we need the routes
and that's it for the moment so first
let's create
the database file so we need here to add
the connection
connection that go also the package is
database
so usually the package name is the name
of the directory
so i will cut this code
i will go to connection.go and here i'll
create a function
i'll call it connect and i'll paste
this code so we need also to import the
driver
so drivermysql
and we will be using this function here
in main.gov
so first let's import the database
so to import it we have to use dot slash
database so we import
the directory and to use the function we
use
the package first connect
and this won't change anything now let's
add the route so
create here go file routes
i'll create a function setup
and inside i will cut this code
and i will put it here
so we need up here so the app should be
passed
as a property here so up
is a star fiber
up
and uh let's pass up here so we need to
import also
the routes in the routes
we'll set up the routes and we will pass
up inside
so we have we are done with this also
now we need this function so this
function
should be added in the controller so
let's create
a go file i will call it house
controller
here i will create a function hello
and this function so i will paste this
function first
and i will name it here hello
and now let's use this function let's go
to the routes
and here we need to import
the controllers
and to call the function we have to call
here controllers
hello just like this
and now let's run our app
and this will return the same
so we restructured our
files and now let's create the register
function
so i will rename this to register
and in the routes this will be the
register function
and this will be a post request to
api slash register
i'll stop the server for the moment
and now let's go to the register
function
and for the moment let's return what the
data we will send with the post request
so to get the data from the post request
i will declare a variable data here
which will be a map string
string so this is similar to a
array with a string as a key and string
as a value so to pass the data
we have to call a function c
body parser and we will pass the data
as a reference this way we will
get all the request data that we will
send
this returns an error
so we should handle there
there are two ways to end the layer one
is to add an if condition here
if error is not nil then
we return the error or an
an even shorter way which is uh i will
add the if condition here
and i will add an exclamation here
and this looks uh shorter and cleaner
now we got we handle the error we got
the data
and now let's return see
json the data to see what we send so
to see the data that we sent first make
sure to install postman
i already did it so now let's send a
post request
to http localhost port 8000
api register
this is a post request and what we want
to send
is a raw request so we'll send a name
name email
aaa.com
and the password which will be
one send
so i didn't start the server
so we returned exactly what we sent so
if i
change this to a
this will change now we got the data now
we have to store this data
in the database so let's create
a user table in our database
to do that we have to create a directory
now
models and inside this directory i'll
create a go file
called user and let's create a struct
for the user so structs
are similar to classes in other
languages so
type user
struct and this user will have an id
as an unsigned integer a name
as a string an email
as a string and a password
as a string
so this is our user struct now let's
create a migration to create a table in
our database
so let's use the connection for our
database here
so get the connection
and to migrate we have an option here
connection auto migrate
so let's import the models
models and we need to auto migrate the
user so
we add and here models
user with this we can auto migrate
the users let's refresh here we don't
have any tables
and if i restart the server
we can see a users table was created
so we have this table with all the
fields
that we need so
we can add also extra configuration for
example
i want this email to be unique so i
add here gorm
uniq
with this this will make the email
unique
if i restart the server
refresh and as we can see the email was
generated unique so
gorm is a pretty powerful library
now let's create the user here
so first let's create a user variable
which is equal so first let's import the
models here
which is equal to models
user and we need to pass
the name which is data
name like this
we need to pass the email which is data
email
and we need to pass the password but the
password we won't set the password
directly like this
because we need to hash the password so
let's get a package to hash our password
to search for gop packages go to go.dev
and click discover packages here we need
a package
called bcrypt
and this is a package that we want
copy the link here so we can install it
so
go get bcrypt
so i already did it and now we can add
here
bcrypt now let's use it so let's create
a variable
password and we return also an
error which i won't handle it is equal
to bcrypt
generate from password and we need to
pass our password
so data password
but this won't accept a string so what
we need to do here is to convert these
two
in a slice of bytes so bite
like this and
the other parameter is a cost which i
will put 14 here
so the this is how we generate
a password and we needed to
make it as a byte array and this new
password can be assigned here
the problem is that this password
is a byte array also so how do we
convert it
the best way is to make this password
also a byte array
like this so with this
we can use this
hashed password but also we need to auto
migrate to the database
so for the moment i will return the user
here because every variable needs to be
used
and let's restart the server to
see the changes here
actually we won't see any changes
because the byte array
is you it will be still returned as a
long text here so
everything will work fine now
if we send the request again like we did
before
we will see that the password
is hashed and also we return an id here
which is
zero so we haven't assigned that id in
the user
model if we don't assign anything it
will
initialize it 0 for numbers
and empty strings for strings
so now let's insert this user to the
database
and we have to get this variable here so
how do we share this variable from this
folder to the auth controller
we have to create a global variable
right now
where db is
a pointer to gorm db
and we have to assign it with this
variable here so
db is equal to the connection
so these two pointers are referencing
the same variable which is the database
connection
now we use this variable in our
controller
so let's get the database
and to get the variable we have to use
database
db so with this we got
this variable so the connection and
we have to create now
and we will pass the user as a reference
like this
so with this we can insert this user to
the database
let's try it send a request so this
won't create
because i forgot to restart the server
send it again and now as we can see the
id
is one so we successfully inserted the
user in the database
let's see
so this is our generated user
so our user is created
now let's login with this user so let's
create a function
login this will have the same parameters
and let's add it also to the routes
so this will post to api slash login
and the function is controllers login
so we added this now let's make
the login work so we will get
the data like the register function
so we will send here an email and a
password
so by the email we want to get the user
with that email
so first let's get a variable user
as a models user
and now we need to call the database db
where
email is equal to question mark
and the email value is data
email and we want to get the first
result and we want to assign it to this
user
variable so with this we will get
the user based on the email
if the user
id is equal to zero
this means that we haven't found the
user so we have to
set the status to fiber
status not
found 404 basically
and we have to return here see
json fiber
map message
user not found
so if we don't find the user
we return status not found and we return
this message so fiber map is basically
a map with a string and interface so we
can
put anything there
if we got the user then we have to
compare the password
so to compare the password we have
another
function from bcrypt which is compare
and hash password
so the first parameter is the user
password
which is a hashed value and the second
parameter
is a byte so we have to convert it also
to bytes
of the password that we have so data
password this returns
an error
and if an error happens
so let's make it shorter so error is not
nil here
then we send the status so
status fiber
status bad request
and we return c
json fiber
[Music]
map message
incorrect password
so if we get an error here it means that
the password is not correct
if we go here it means that we
successfully
uh send the right email we retrieve the
user
and we got the right password so for the
moment
i will return see
json the user
and let's see if this works so i'll copy
this
url i'll paste it here and this will be
login let's send a post request let's
send the body so this will be an email
a at a.com and the password
is what is the password one
so for the moment i'll send the
wrong email
so did i restart the server
user not found so if i put the wrong
email
it means the user is not found if i put
the wrong password
incorrect password if i put the right
one
then we retrieve the user so
we successfully retrieve the user here
but
we want to return a jwt token
to return a jwt token we need to install
another package
jwt and
this is a package that we want to use
so let's copy the url and
install it here
go get this package
i already have it so i can use here
on top
and now let's create a jwt token
so first we need the claims variable
which is equal to this package jwt
new with claims
so this is a function we need a method
which
we get it from jwt
signing method hs2245 so there are a lot
of methods but i will use
this hs 2
5 6 and
the second parameter is jwt
standard claims and inside
we will pass an issuer the issuer is our
user so
what we want to pass here is the user
id unfortunately the user id
is not a string so this accepts a string
so let's convert the user id
to a string so first we have to import
here
str conf and this can convert
this to a string so we use strconf
we use this function
which i cannot pronounce it and this
accepts an
ins so user id is
you in so this user
id cannot be sent like this but we have
to convert this to an int
so like this we converted the user id
to a string
so this is claims
and we need an expiry expired sat so
let's
import also time here
and when we want to expire this token
so we have to pass time now
we need to add time
hour times
24 so this means is one day
and this needs to be converted to unix
time
so this is our claims
so it will expire after 24 hours
so now let's create a token
and we will get also an error
is equal to claims
sign string
and here we need to pass a byte
array
of secret
so this secret is a secret key that we
need to store it in our app so
create a constant variable here on top
so const
secret key
and this secret key
should be stored in our app and
now let's handle the error so if the
error
is not nil we return
the error or we return a better message
so i will do it like this
we return internal server error
and the message is
could not log in
so we got this now let's return the
token
and let's see it so let's login again so
let's restart the server
send the request and as we can see this
is a token that
we generated now we don't want to
return it like this we want to store it
in cookies so let's create a cookie
is equal to fiber cookie
so to create a cookie we need a name
i'll name it jwt
value the value is a token itself
expires so let's copy this
part here and this
needs not a unix time this needs a time
like this
and the last one is http only
it's important to add http only here
because the front end
cannot access this cookie
so this cookie is meant only to be
stored in the front end and stay and
send it but the front end
doesn't need to access it and
to save it we need to
add here c cookie
cookie
select this as a reference
and that's it so in the end we can
return fiber
map
message success
because we don't want to return the
cookie
the front end will only have the cookie
and nothing more so it won't
be able to access it or use it so
this is not enough we need to add here
on main another
configuration so first
our front end will have course issues
so we need to use up use
we need to use course
new so don't forget also to import this
url here so course problems are the
problems
that uh our backend will run on port
8000 and
the front end will run on different port
so if we don't add this uh
our browser won't allow the request and
it will draw an error
if we add this then it will
ignore that and we will have the request
still we need also one configuration
which is
course config
allow credentials to true so this is
really important
and with this the front end can get
the cookie that we sent and
it can send it back so this is really
important
if we want to authenticate using
http only cookies so with this
let's test it we don't have any cookies
and let's send the request
so i forgot again to restart the server
so message is success but we see here
we have a cookie jwt which is http only
so we need to use this cookie now to
retrieve the logged in
user so let's do it now function
user
i will copy this part
and i will add this to the route so
this is a get request api slash
user and controllers user
let's go to the functional and what do
we want to do with
this function first we have to get the
cookie
so the cookie is cookie
is equal to c cookies
and we need the name which is jwd with
this
we got the cookie now let's retrieve the
token so the token
and an error are equal to jwd
pars with claims
so this function accepts first
the cookie because the cookie is a
string
right now we need the claims
the claims are gwt standard claims so we
need to pass it with
reference and the third parameter is a
function
which accepts
a token and the jwd token is a
reference and this will return an
interface
and an error so inside this function
we need to return the secret key that
we generated here so we have to return
a byte array of
the secret key and
the error is nil so we don't want to
return an error
and that's it so if the error
is not nil then
we want to return i'll copy this
paste it here fiber status
unauthorized and the message is
unauthenticated
so if this returns an error it means
that the user is not logged in
and now we got the token
let's get the claims from the token so
claims
are equal to token
claims and let's
return them c json claims
so let's test this function
and i will copy this url paste it here
and this is a get request to user
send the request and as we can see we
have an expiry
time and also an issuer so this is the
idea of our user
so we got the issuer here and now let's
retrieve the
id but there is a problem
claims has only a valid function
it doesn't have an issuer function
why is that the case because this claims
is a is an interface
that has only a valid function what do
we want
is to return a standard claims
and this has our issue that we want
so how do we convert these
claims to a standard claims to convert
it we have to use
dot parenthesis and this will be
converted to
jwt standard claims so this is how we
convert
one type to another and now these claims
will have the issuer that we want
so now let's use this issuer in order to
retrieve the user
so let's first create a variable
user is a type of models user
and now let's query the database
database db
where id
is equal to question mark and the id is
claims
issuer the first
result is our user
and in the end we want to return the
user
let's see so let's restart the server
so we got an error
so as we can see we converted this to a
standard claims but this needs to be a
pointer of standard claims
let's restart again the server
and we successfully retrieve the user
so with this
we don't send anything we only send the
cookies
and we treat the user i forgot to
mention that
if we open a new tab the cookie will be
preserved that's why we retrieve the
user here
so we got the user and
one thing before we log out i would like
to change the format here
of the attributes here
so first i don't want to show the
password and second i want
this to be lowercase so how do i do this
let's go to the user here we can add
some configuration
like how the json will return so
this id will return like this
the name will return like this
email we can add it here
like this so this can support multiple
configurations
and the password
we put a minus here which means that we
don't want to return the password
with this let's restart the server
send request again and this is our user
so
name email all lower case
and the password is not returned now
let's add the last function which is
logout
now let's copy this part
and to log out now we have to remove the
cookie that we just created here
so how do we remove cookies to remove
cookies
is really strange because we don't
actually
remove it cookie
to remove cookies we create another
cookie
and we set the expiry time in the past
so let's create this cookie
the name will be jwt
the value will be an empty string
the expiry so this is the part that
we will remove our cookie
so we set the expiry time to now
and we will add here
a time which is time hour
with a minus so this cookie expired
one hour ago and http only is equal to
true
so this is how we remove cookies there
is no way to remove
the cookies in the browser just we set
the expiry time in the past
so with this the cookie will be removed
we have to set the cookie
and to the response and let's return the
response
so return c json
fiber map
message
success
and that's it so let's add it to the
routes
logout
logout so with this
we completed the logout function let's
send
so first let's restart the server
let's copy the url here paste it here
this is logout and we need to send a
post request
so before i delete the cookie we have
the cookie here so we retrieve the user
and let's send a post request to the
logout
method not allowed so this is a post
request
let's restart
send it again and we have message
success and the cookie
is removed here so if we
send the request to the user now we get
unauthenticated
because we don't have the cookie if we
log in again
we generate another cookie then we
retrieve the user
so this is how authentication works
in golang thank you for watching this
video
and make sure to like and subscribe
now to install react make sure you have
node.js installed
if you have not js installed right open
the terminal and write
this command mpx create
react app now we need the name of the
app i'll call it
react auth and i will add
template typescript
i like to use typescript on my projects
now let's wait till it
is completed
so the project is created now let's go
to the folder
and run npm start
react will run on port 3000 localhost
port 3000
so this is our running react app
now i will open the project with my ide
also i will close the terminal here
so let's use it directly in my ide
here npm start
so nothing has changed now
i will delete the test file and let's
add the template
for our project so
let's go to get bootstrap.com
go to get started first and let's add
the bootstrap link to our
index.html
i'll add it here
so we added bootstrap now let's add a
template
so the template that we want is this
sign-in form here
let's inspect our viewpage source better
and here i will copy the
div here the main div and
i will add it to up.tsx so i'll paste it
here so i'll keep the
class name up here now
it's complaining because some tags
are not closed i'll make some changes so
i'll remove the
image here i will
add a closing tag here for the input
i will remove all the labels
i will remove this also and this
so this needs also a closing tag
also make sure to change class to
class name so
these are class here and i change it to
class name
my id automatically does it if yours
doesn't make sure to change it
this now will look like this
still is not looking good
we still have to add the styles here so
go to sign in the css here
copy all the code and add it to our app
css i'll paste it here
save it so it looks
a little bit better so let's
remove this body and html styles here
and now it looks better so
this is not a css tutorial so if you
want to learn css
you can watch other tutorials i will
cover only the authentication part here
now here in the form let's remove this
id here and this out of focus
i want to keep everything really simple
and this won't change anything
so it doesn't now i want to add here a
menu so we can navigate to different
pages
so go again to get bootstrap.com
examples
and here i will get a navigation menu
so which one is the simplest
i'll pick this navbar static
i'll view the paste source here and i
will copy
the navigation here
and i will paste it here on top
so still we need to close the tags that
are not closed so we have a form here
with a button
so let's close first the input here
and let's remove this tab index and i
guess we don't have
any problems so don't forget also to cl
change the class with the class name
so this is our menu now
let's uh remove some stuff
we don't need this button so we just
need
i will name this home here
also i will remove this form
and for the list items here
i'll keep only one so i will remove the
classes here
and this will be login
and i will add another one for the
register
so what is missing that is complaining
maybe i forgot to close the ul here
so it's working fine
now let's split this into components
so create a directory
actually i'll call it pages
and the pages that we want is the login
dot tsx
so tsx is the version of
jsx the typescript version of jsx
so create your component i have a
shortcut for creating a component so you
should
write it yourself if you don't have that
shortcut
let's add the html here and this this
login form
so i'll cut this
and i will add it to the login tsx
for the moment i will just add here
login make sure also to import it
because my id
dot does it automatically and i'll
create
a new component called navigation so
components i'll call it
a nav so this is a tsx
file also i'll cut this code
and i will paste it so let's create the
component
i'll paste it here navigation
so i will add it
like this it doesn't work
so i will import it
so nothing has changed so close the
other tabs
and now let's add other pages
and let's add the router so we can move
to
other pages so we need a register
so i'll just name it register for the
moment
and another page called home
home here
so let's add them these pages
here but we cannot replace them
because we have to add another package
so
let's install it npm install react
router dom and the typescript version so
react router done
every time you install a package the
typescript version
has it types in front of it
so the package now is installed
now let's use it so
let's wrap let's change this login here
to browser router
import also browser router from reactor
router dom
and to add the pages we have to add
route
we need to import also route here
and this has a path
so the main page so just slash will be
the home component so here
we will add home
so import also home here
slash login will be the login component
and slash register
will be the register component
let's see if it works so we have home
here so we are the home component
now we cannot move because we haven't
made the links work
but we can go to other pages with login
here
we can see the login page but we see
home here
why do we see home there is because
the path matches the path with the
register here
and if we want to distinguish we have to
add here
exact so this is the exact path and now
we don't have
home there register also that works
so every component
has been rendered now let's add the
links to the navigation
so we have to change this anchor links
right now
two links
from react router dom so import link
from react router dom and this
will point to
the main page let's change
also this
other parts so this will point
to slash login
and this is linked to
slash register
let's see and we get an error
there is that you should not use links
outside a router so the error is because
the navigation is outside the browser
router
and we can fix that by moving the
browser router here
and using
the navigation inside and now
everything is correct we can navigate
to other pages now let's complete
the register because we have to register
first
so we can log in now let's go to the
register
and the form will be similar with a
login
and i will paste it here please
register
and this is submit
the register form has an email has a
password and also
has a first a name just a name
so name
email and password i kept it really
simple
so this is the register form now
let's make this form work first
we have to for every input we have to
get
a variable and
[Music]
we have to use the state for every
variable so we have to get here the name
set name is equal to use
state and inside is the default value
which will be an empty string
so this is how we handle state in react
[Music]
the first is a variable and the second
one
is an actual function that changes this
variable
so i will add
two other states one is for the email
and this is set email here and the last
one is password
set password so where do we use these
variables
so let's use the functions first and
we will use the functions once we change
the input so we will add here listener
on
change and what will happen
when we change the input will fire an
event
and we'll set the name
to event.target.value
so every time we change the name
we will set the name here we will use
the function
let's do the same for the other inputs
set email
and this is set password
so we set all the variables now we need
to submit the
form so we have a non-submit function
here
and let's create a function called
submit
and we will use it here
so this function accepts an event
and since we are in typescript we have
to
define the type of this event and is a
type of
synthetic event
so don't forget also to import it
when we submit a form it usually
refreshes the page so in our case
i will just show it to you
i'll console log here
the name
the email and the password
so i'm keeping this short because this
is the same as name
and the name variable but since they are
the same
i can use it directly like this
and let's see if we console log
here so
submit so we saw console.log here but
the page
was refreshed and to prevent that we
have to add
event.preventdefault
and now if we try to login to register
sorry
we console.log the actual values
so now we have to use
this values and to send it to our
backend so i will cut this
and let's send a request to the server
using fetch first i will make this
function a synchronous
and to get the response from the server
is equal to await fetch
we have to pass here the endpoint which
is http
localhost port
slash api register
so this is a get request but we have to
make it a post request
we have to add here the method which is
post and
we have to add also the body
and the body is the json that we
cut but we have to make it to a string
so
json stringify and we will
paste the values we need also
a header so headers here
and the header that we want to send is
content type
application json
and that's it basically so
the content is equal to weight response
json and let's log
the content here so let's see what the
server does
return to us
so i still have the form here i will try
to console.log
submit and we created a user right now
so the response was successful
and what do we want to do once we
successfully register a user we we want
to redirect to the login
so we'll remove all this and add another
state here
so first to redirect
we have to use redirect
we need to import it also
redirect from react router dom and we
have to return it
redirect to
login so this is the way
we redirect and as we can see we are at
the login page but
now we cannot go to the register because
we
automatically redirect so we have to add
a condition here
if i'll create a variable
just like the other variables this will
be redirect
and set redirect
is equal to use state and the default
state will be
false so by default
if redirect
we won't redirect because it is false
and now we can stay to the register page
when we want to redirect is when this
fetch
has finished so here we'll set redirect
to true
with this once we register with another
user
test.com
and now i am at the login page
so now let's login
go to the login page and just like the
register
i'll get the email and the password here
and i will paste them here also
when they change so
on change we want to set
the email to event.target.value
and same for the password
set password
now we need to submit the form on submit
here let's create the submit function
submit and this will have an event which
is a synthetic
event and event.prevent
default here so everything is
correct now we need to send a
request to the login so i will copy this
i'll paste it here and the end point so
make this asynchronous then point now
is api login
and we don't have the name so
that's it so we need to send the email
and the password but this is
not enough so we can send the
credentials
and they will be correct but
we need to get the cookie from the
server
to get the cookie from the server we
need to add another configuration
another option which is credentials to
true
it's not true it's include so
with this when we login we will get
the cookies from the backend so let's
see it
in the application now we don't have any
cookies
and let's try to login ata.com
a as we can see we generated a cookie
which is http only
so the request was successful
we got to the message here but we don't
do anything to set it to the cookies so
we just
send the request and nothing more but
since we have these credentials
include here it means that
we will get this cookie now
in every request and this is a cookie
that we need to use to our home to get
the
authenticated user so just like
the register right now when we log in
we want to redirect so
i will copy and paste the same thing
and we want to redirect to the main page
here
and set redirect to true
so let's try to login again
and we are at the home page here we want
to display
the user so let's uh
here we need to call the user and
since we don't have anything we have to
use another function which is
use effect
so
here we need to call a backend and
i will do it like this since
user effect doesn't accept async
functions so this is not allowed
and we have to call the backend
uh i would like to make my function
asynchronous and we have
i want to do it like this so this is
short for
executing this asynchronous function
here
so i like it like this and you can use a
different way of
calling the back end and
i'll copy this
send it to the home now we don't want to
send a post request
and this method is get
by default is get and this will be user
here
and that's it basically now let's see if
our request will get the user
so we get the authenticated user here
we just the request will get the user we
don't send
anything just a get request and
everything is
gotten from this cookie here and
uh let's before test the cookie
i want to set the name here
so we'll create here a variable
name and set name
and i forgot this is use state
by default is empty string here we'll
say
hi name
so when we get the user here
will get a response
and the content
is equal to weight response.json
and the content in our in this case is
our user
so we'll set the name
to content that's name
let's see if this works hi a so
this is our user that is authenticated
i will make a question mark here
for a so i'll do it like this
a set we will say
hi
with the name otherwise
we will say you are not
authenticated also or not login
so we have high a here if we remove the
cookie
i'll clear it
we get you are not logged in because
we don't have the cookie and the
response is
throwing an error so we have to login
again
and now we show the name
again here now the last thing that is
left to change
is the logout here for the login and
register
when we are logged in we want to show
the logout button
but there is a problem here because we
get the user here on the home component
and the the buttons are in the nav
component
so how do we fix this problem
this problem will be fixed if we move
this function i will move it so i will
also get the set names
to the up.tsx because
this up here will contain
all the other components so i will paste
it here
so we will get the user here
and we will set this
user to the home component
the way to do it is by extracting this
home component
to a function and we will call it
like this home
and we will set the name is equal to
this
name so this name now
is a property we have to access it via
props here and
since it is typescript props need to be
defined with the type and this will have
a name
which is a string
so we add the props here and what is
left
is to use the props like this
so props that name and props that name
here
so nothing has changed and also
this component doesn't have any errors
so this is how we pass values
via the props so these props
will be the same in the nav so we
need to pass the same props
and in the update esx
we'll pass here the name as a name here
so if the name is empty we will show
this values so let's add a condition
here
i'll make a menu
and this menu if
the name
is empty
not name that but that name
then the menu will be similar to this
one
so by default
if the user is not logged in we'll
display
this html if the user is logged in so we
have an else here
then the menu is equal to
i'll still copy this because i need the
styles
but i will remove this and now we need a
link to
login but this will be logout function
and now we can see log out here now
let's make this logout work
so we have to add here and unclick
and let's create a logout function so
where should i create it i'll create it
here on top
and this function
i'll call it here
like this so we have to call again
the backend so this
is a post request also
i'll copy this paste it here this is an
asynchronous function
this doesn't have to have a synthetic
event
we don't have to send the body because
we don't want to send data
and the function the endpoint is logout
and that's it when we send this request
we will clear our cookie and
since we link to login when we click
logout we will get redirected also to
login so we will do two things at once
let's log out and we are at
the login page if we go there
we still see our name and logout here
but if we refresh
everything will be normal but why this
is happening
uh also when we log in the same thing
happens so i will see the
cookies here ata.com here
a so we got the cookies but still it
says
no you're not logged in and the only way
to show it
is by refreshing so the login and the
logout
work totally totally fine there is still
a minor change that we have to make so
when we log out we have to tell
other components that we are actually
logged out
and i will do it the same with this name
and now when we log out we have to emit
an event to the other components
and i will add another prop here i'll
call it set
name and this is a
function
that returns void and accepts a name as
a string
so once we finish
the logout here we'll set the name
prop sorry set name
to empty
and that's it so what
did we do right now so now now in our
app.esx
we'll need a function set name
and it will send an empty string so
we want to set the name so we have
another set name function here
set name and this will work
the same so when we log out
we successfully log out but we don't
reset the name to an empty string here
so that
is the solution so we have to reset the
name
right here and when we login
we have to do the same so we have to set
the name so let's
first test the logout so now
we have the jwt let's log out
and now immediately we can see login and
register here
so it we successfully logged out
but when we login still we have the same
problem that you are not logged in
so let's emit a set name also from the
login
let's go to login and we have to
emit the same thing again here
and we have to get the response
and the content
is equal to a weight response.json
and let's emit the event so the props
here i'll copy it from the navigation
so let's go to the login we'll have
props
that this will have a function that will
set the name like this
props here set name
content dot name
and that's it and
in the update dsx we have to use it just
like home here
uh not name actually is it name not home
sorry is login the function is set name
and we will call set name
so i made a mistake somewhere
and we have to close it
so let's try to so
everything is correct right now logout
we don't see here the name let's login
so we didn't redirect but we see the
login
and everything works fine maybe we
should change
the order here
logout ata.com
and everything works fine so we
completed our
login register and this is how login
works in react
so thank you for watching this video
please
like share and subscribe thank you